[Musique]
ce moment d'histoire a aussi été un
moment d'ouverture et d'euphorie pour
des anonymes dont le destin a basculé ce
jour-là comme cette jeune femme qui
voulait à tout prix passer à l'Ouest et
ce policier estallemand qui aurait dû
l'en empêcher mais qui n'en a rien fait
15 ans après nous les avons retrouvé le
reportage est signé Julien Colombani et
Miriam
metaoui le mur tombé enfin des milliers
et des milliers d''est Allemands se
moquant du rideau de fer retrouvé
d'autres allemands que plus de 40 ans de
guerre froide avait séparé
[Applaudissements]
de gardait la frontière il était un
policier de RDA Gessler est la première
à avoir osé passer à l'Ouest chaque
citoyen de RDA qui veut traverser la
frontière doit avoir un laissé passer
mais les formalités iront plus vite pour
avoir un vis de sortie ma mère et mon
père sont là-bas c'est possible les voir
aujourd'hui 15 ans après leur cœur
palpite encore à se souvenir qu'est-ce
que j'ai pu boire comme champagne cette
nuit-là j'ai jamais été aussi saoule
l'ancien policier a dû attendre de
semaines pour avoir le droit de
traverser ce qui était encore une
frontière c'était un sentiment étrange
tout était nouveau les vitrines des
magasins n'avaient rien à voir avec
celle de chez
nous ce qui m'a un peu dérangé à
l'époque c'est que mes anciens
compatriotes se sont précipités à
l'ouest
comme des singes devant des
bananes sans beaucoup de
dignitéterbok est resté vivre à l'est
aujourd'hui il s'occupe de jeunes en
difficulté kertine elle a déménagé de
l'autre côté du pont dans un quartier
périphérique de Berlin Ouest et depuis
tant de choses ont changé dans sa vie il
a fallu s'adapter passer d'un régime
communiste qui réglait votre vie à un
monde libre dans lequel il faut se
battre
ici c'est comme je me l'imaginais sauf
en ce qui concerne le poids de
l'administration il faut toujours aller
s'inscrire quelque part courir partout à
l'Est c'était pas comme ça par exemple
si on avait besoin d'un appartement on
passait un coup de fil et c'était réglé
aujourd'hui il faut se bagarrer avec
d'autres candidats il faut une caution
tout ça c'est nouveau pour
moi après pas mal de petits boulottine
est aujourd'hui sans emploi comme
beaucoup à Berlin où l' déombre chur
mais contrairement à certains anciens
citoyens d'Allemagne de l'Est il est
hors de question pour elle de regretter
quoi que ce soit